So, I’m now going to teach you a concept that
is very deep, called the density of a probability.
And it’s kind of like a probability for continuous
spaces but not exactly. It’s just a good motivator
to think of a density as a – of a probability for
continuous spaces. Let’s take the bottle
example. We know that the outcome of turning
the bottle lies between 0 and 360 degrees.
So, given what we learnt, you want to assign
0 to anything outside that range but inside
this range, we’d love to give a value and say,
look, there is a function here that renders
every outcome in this interval equally likely.
So, you’re going to construct this function for
So, you’re going to construct this function for c
number one, each outcome in the range of 0
to 360 has an equal value, and, constraint
number two, the area under this function sums
up or integrates to 1 which means this area
over here is just 1. So, tell me what is this
function for X’s that are between 0 and 360
degrees. There is a single numerical value
that goes in here and you have to guess it.